Nice purple badge. And we've got my friend, my, my, uh,
Don now Rawlings given him a round of applause. Everybody.
I don't want to round on pause. I want to, first of all,
I wanna apologize to all my fans that are going to look at this and say,
what the is he doing? Desperate times. We cry desperate.
First of all, first of all, we'd be clear for everyone.
Let them know that I don't want to be here. Okay. Let me be clear. No, no, no,
because people like all, they got such a friendship in a bucket.
I don't want to be here. The only reason I want to be clear,
the only reasons, and this is probably, I don't understand Bobby,
this podcast has so many fans. Exactly. Thank you. Look at it.
Like a person that's going on a TV show.
He know they're going to ask some dumb questions,
but it's so many viewers that you got to go there. I don't this.
The only reason I'm here is because, uh,
there are people that we're not the Kelly Clarkson show.
Is that what you're saying? No, not now. Clark said no,
but people go on there because it has got a lot of viewership.
Is that what he's saying? Yeah. That's exactly what I'm going to say to you is.
Yeah. Yes. And if my pockets and more viewers, I would never be on this
[inaudible]. I need to, the people in the streets told me,
they said you want to be a part of what? The facts are. Facts. Okay.
Facts are facts. All right. And it's so interesting that you say that.
Cause I wasn't even gonna bring this up,
but it's like when you started your new podcast, right.
You're trying to start a little war with me right on Instagram.
Which to me made it seem like you wanted to come onto our podcast and you
want to collaborate. No, I wanted to with you. Yeah. Oh, you want to with me?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I wanted to, like, I like fighting you. I like
fighting you. I like funny,
but I had to stop the fight because nobody wanted to join the team.
You were too deep, real deep in the Asian community.
When it comes to like do with
like hacking or anything like that, I'm going to lose.
You don't even have this many viewers. We have one young Asian
that created some type of robot.
[inaudible] nah, I like football. I like with you too.
But there is something with us that whenever I see you,
sometimes you'll like walk the other way. Or you, you, even before the pandemic,
you would create a distance because you, you, you can't handle my,
my sexual energy. Okay. You guess what?
This is why you're such a genius because I don't know how many years
it took you to figure it out. Yeah.
I can't handle sexual energy from anybody with a Dick. You know what I'm saying?
Like sexual energy to you for you.
I just exude it because I'm just a being, I know you're a B,
but I'm not that type of being right. We're different type of beings.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. And this is why I say, I know this.
I know you're from a place where like, and this may sound weird for some people.
Yeah. Were kissing the guy in the mouth. It's not considered a homosexual.
I don't. I find it European. I don't find it homeless. That's my point.
I'm not a European. But you do, you do know Europe exists.
I do have so many European. This is like some of my favorite bits,
but it's that? They're. Yeah. Alright. They have vaginas, right?
I don't do they not purple vagina. Okay. But they have a giant,
that's the difference in cultures? Let me just say this then. Okay.
For instance, if I was at home in my head it's it's it's good.
Yeah. Yeah. I really like nature. And we'll get to that later. Well,
you could of rock that hat. You could have rock that hat 30 years ago.
I could rock. I got swag. I can rock anything.
I think 30 years ago would have been weird. Now, as you're older,
you asked me a question, Bobby, I'm giving you my answer. And you said no.
So are you going to interview me or are you going to interview your school?
[inaudible] go leave. Don't leave
somebody to bounce ideas off.
Yay. I'm disturbed by this plexiglass. you. Call it. Yeah.
Cause I know you're trying to prep. Prep, prep, practice, correct.
COVID protocol.
But me being from the hood and you being Asian on the other end side of
glass. Yeah. This is where you guys get empowered. Like
I'm telling you like it's certain neighborhoods like the
Asian person talked to more. The thicker,
the Bulletproof glass right now. You're not going to talk to my.
Cause I could kick myself through this right here. You was like,
you, you on my show.